ومعسل ان ديبوار ان لم تنتهي الحرب فسيكون
من الصعب على العالم المضي قدما بهذه
الكلمات استهلت افتتاحيه القمه التي وصفت
بالاصعب لان ملفتها المعهوده لم تتمحور
فحسب على القضايا الاقتصاديه وانما طغت
عليها المساله الاوكرانيه فلا صياغه متفقا
عليها حول وصف ما يجري على ارضها عدوان ام
عمليه عسكريه يخطر الرئيس الصيني شيجن نحو
حضوره القمه وهو مدرك ان عده دول تحاول
التقرب من بلاده
الصين لم تتفوه بكلمه ضد روسيا لكن تحذير
شيء جيم بينج من تسليح الغذاء والطاقه رجح
على انه انتقاد مبطن وفي الوقت ذاته اعرب
عن معارضته لسياسه العقوبه الغربيه
قمه تاريخيه ان صح التعبير فجلد خلافه
عميقه قد يذوب بين الصين ودول اخرى بدا
باول مصافحه حاره بين اكبر اقتصادين في
العالم ثم باثنتين وثلاثين دقيقه مثلت
تحولا دبلوماسيا مهما بين استراليا والصين
فرنسا لم تكن غائبه عن المشهد لان الرئيس
ايمان والماكرون اكد انه اتفق مع نظيره
الصيني على سياده اوكرانيا
قمه غاب عنها الرئيس الذي مر بوتين لكن
وزير الخارجيه سيرغيلا بروف كان لسانه
الحاضر الذي لم ينفك عن اعتبار ان ما تقوم
به بلاده في اوكرانيا مشروعا مشددا على
عدم تاسيس البيان الختامي ضد روسيا
ووفقه ما كشفت المسوده فان مواقف اغلبيه
الدول الاعضاء مستوره حول نزاع روسيا
واوكرانيا بعضهم وجد ان الوقت قد حان لوضع
حد لروسيا وعزلها والاخر يقول انها ليست
المنصه المخصصه لحل القضايا الامنيه لتبدو
والصين عقلانيه في استخدام عبارتها التي
وزنتها مانيا حتى على لسان وزير خارجيتها
الذي رفض استخدام كلمه العدوان الروسي
مؤكدا ان بكين لن تتوانى عن لاعبي دور
بناء باي محادثات سلام بين موسكو
اسراء الصغير العربيه